tanka recently sat down to interview the
author of a new book on the crisis
afflicting American men here's what
happened if you look at the numbers you
quickly conclude that men are in crisis
in America compared to women they are
far more likely to drop out of school
fail to graduate go to jail not hold a
job commit suicide die of a drug
overdose and yet the establishment in
particularly Democratic establishment
seems uninterested in all of this and
anything they appear to think that men
are still too successful and need to be
held back
andrew yarrow is a former New York Times
reporter senior fellow with the
progressive Policy Institute he just
wrote an important new book called man
out men on the sidelines of American
life he joins us tonight in studio
Monsieur euro thank you very much for
coming on Thank You times by saying I
don't think you're a conservative
activist and that I'm also grateful that
someone is saying this because the
numbers support that it's true it is
true and as you say the problem has
really largely been ignored
I mean Democrats and a lot of people in
the country don't see Nemus having
problems but there are a lot of men who
is struggling struggling with work
struggling families struggling with
health a lot of areas I touch on my part
well it's just such a great extent that
it would seem a crisis that affects
everybody because of course men and
women need each other to reproduce on
the most basic level but also every
everybody has a father or brothers sons
right why do you think it's been ignored
well there's been a lot of political
correctness in this country that's kind
of made the main narrative be that you
know women are the oppressed ones and
they have been historically oppressed
but you know that doesn't mean that
there aren't a lot of men struggling I
mean you don't it's not a zero-sum game
right and it's been presented as one
that one sec succeeds only when another
moves backward where'd that assumption
comes
well I think a lot of politics looks at
things that way and I think it's it's
pretty unfortunate but I think you know
men have not been in many ways good at
advocating for themselves I mean it's
been interesting in the last few
elections a lot of the political
activists have been women I mean you
hear more from women these days I mean
men aren't good at forming groups and
yes so you work at the progressive
Policy Institute your foe there that's
not the Heritage Foundation right
I think it's vertice probably work in a
mostly liberal world what kind of
reaction did your piece get among people
you know well it's interesting
conservative media have tended to like
it more it's you know it's kind of
troubling that this should be a
bipartisan issue I mean all Americans
should be doing well or should have the
opportunity to do well and they should
also have justice behind them I mean men
are being accused wrongly I mean there
are a lot of awful things that men do
don't get me wrong but you know the lack
of due process and some of these sexual
assault allegations it's you know it's
pretty troubling it's just interesting
because the most progressive president
the country's ever had FDR he's four
terms the first thing he did after
getting elected in 1932 the very first
piece through the Congress was the CCC
the Civilian Conservation Corps which
was aimed at young men he just meant
between 18 and 25 or something like that
getting them back to work and restoring
their vitality through work what would
happen if a Democrat in the modern era
suggested something like that well you
think it would play well you know while
the unemployment statistics look good
there are a lot of men who have either
been pushed out of the labor force or
dropped out I mean they're about 17 18
percent of 25 to 64 year old men who
aren't working and you know there are a
lot of younger men who are neither in
school or working so you know why is
that and you know why can't we create
better jobs for them
and yes I mean you'd think a Democrat
would pitch some kind of jobs program I
think I mean this is a longer
conversation I think the answer is toxic
masculinity yeah well yeah I mean that's
become the phrase du jour I guess I mean
they're clearly issues with masculinity
you know I interviewed a lot of Pitman
and some women around the country about
200 and a lot of men told me a lot of
you know even liberal men said well
feminism's done a lot for women but
what's it done for me that's a that's a
fair question and you ask it in this
book thank you for doing that
thank you we talk to you good to talk to
you